for the very first time the woman who
says she was attacked
by former seattle seahawks player chad
wheeler is speaking out
last week you may recall wheeler pleaded
not guilty to three charges including
domestic violence assault his
ex-girlfriend showed up in court to face
him
she says that wheeler is still a threat
to her safety
and now she's sharing her story in an
exclusive interview with cbs this
morning
she spoke with our national
correspondent jerica duncan good morning
to you tarika good morning to you gail
her name
is aaliyah taylor and it was a leaked
photo of her injuries that made national
headlines
well now she's ready to share her story
and most importantly she wants domestic
violence survivors to know they're not
alone
we want to warn you some of what you're
about to see and hear
is graphic i still have to
regularly get like my concussion checked
i have
bolts and still on a steel plate i'm
going to have forever in my arm
i'm going to have going to have to deal
with this the rest of my life
that's the reality for 27 year old
aaliyah taylor
after she says she was attacked by her
then boyfriend
chad wheeler taylor says the pair dated
for six months
with barely any arguments we were
like best friends we did everything
together i even
introduced him to my family we would
babysit my nephew together
but according to taylor that all changed
on january 22nd
starting with a text from wheeler that
he shaved his head
he loved just loved this long care
refused to cut it
and it surprised me and it worried me
i came home and chad was trying to play
it off
as if he just kind of cut his hair but
then as time went on throughout the day
he started going downhill emotionally
taylor later told police it was the
beginning of a manic
episode adding she knew wheeler suffered
from bipolar disorder
then according to taylor wheeler snapped
into a dark place
he he stood up and he
told me to bow down and asked him why
and he didn't respond he just told me to
bow down again and i
told him no and he
he immediately grabbed my neck and
that's
that's when things began do you recall
what happened after that when he grabbed
my neck
he he threw me on the bed
and i remember looking up at him and
asking him please stop chad
it's me and
i just immediately knew the look in his
eyes that was it
taylor who is 5'9 says that's when
wheeler
6'7 weighing more than 300 pounds
tried to choke her according to taylor
she blacked out twice
before the attack was over i had touched
my face
and i looked down and there was there
was blood on my hand
and i remember getting up and running to
the bathroom
chad was standing by the bed by the
doorway and he was
sipping his smoothie it was like wow
you're still alive
please now
taylor says she then locked herself in
the bathroom called 9-1-1
and texted her family and wheeler's
father for help
according to police reports it took
three officers
and two sets of handcuffs to restrain
wheeler
police said wheeler kept apologizing as
he was arrested
do you think that chad's behavior
is directly connected to a mental health
issue
to be honest i don't know he went and
ate dinner
after doing this to me and
he didn't take the same approach with
the cops
as he did with me the seahawks dropped
wheeler saying the team
strongly condemns this act of domestic
violence
if convicted wheeler faces eight to 12
years in prison
last week he pleaded not guilty to two
domestic violence related charges
and one count of resisting arrest taylor
was in the courtroom
why was it so important for you to
appear in court
i didn't want him to think that
that he had that power over me that
i wasn't going to defend myself
and i thought how easy would that be for
him and his legal team
to be able to say whatever they want
without
having to look me in the eye do you
think
he should serve prison time for what he
did to you
yes yes i definitely
do think that he should i have to say
the hardest part of all this wasn't
wasn't the surgeries it wasn't eating
that
it was getting a call from my niece and
nephews
they thought they had lost me
and the pain in their voice i will never
forget that
i will never forget that and she doesn't
want her story to be forgotten
either how grateful are you to be alive
beyond grateful i really feel like god
has blessed me with another chance
and i want to try to use the time i've
been blessed with
to help other people and to get the
story out and make sure people don't
feel alone
and that this doesn't happen again cbs
news reached out to the attorneys for
chad wheeler they declined to comment on
the case
wheelish trial is set to begin in
washington state
in april a reminder if you need help
related to domestic violence or
mental health we've posted free
resources on our website cbsnews.com
um a lot of strength exhibited by this
yes very brilliant
so powerful that she's speaking up and
especially the pictures to rico
heartbreaking and you look at the
numbers her height his height
her weight his weight seven five nine
yeah a terrifying change in his demeanor
yes shift six months of dating and then
suddenly that
yeah she said not even an argument um
you could tell she was very conflicted
because she cared
so much about him but this is one of
those uh
difficult stories to tell because it's
not just the domestic violence but also
recognizing that there is a mental
health component in this yes it's
interesting that she had to say to him
at one point chad it's me
it's me right so as a matter of mental
health awareness being bipolar does not
mean you beat up exactly your family
members
exactly um something else
thank you very much